I'm sorry I couldn't help it former  flames Emma Stone and Andrew Garfield  reunite the friendly exes were spotted  laughing together on Saturday got the  governor's awards in Hollywood  Emma clearly telling Andrew a funny  story their expressions say it all the  actors dated for four years after  co-starring in the amazing spider-man  together cuz I love you  that's why she is so specialist because  you can't figure it out it's  unquantifiable she's just the son and  she's got such depth she can do anything  you know she's magic I don't know how  she does it though they split in 2015  they've remained on good terms I just  figured it was time  you know time we try to be friends  pranks last month the source told et  Emma is now dating SNL writer Dave  Meharry explaining quote some of the  show staff knew about them being  together but they keep things very quiet  you